bon
[Musique]
lakovic 19 à bouleverser le quotidien
des ambulanciers chaque patient le
potentiel de lait contaminé et un
technicien paramédical malade et en
moins sur le terrain on sait pas on voit
peau on devient comme un peu
un peu parano je crains c'est sûr depuis
le 1er mars sur les 1000 paramédics
d'urgence-santé y en a neuf qui ont
contracté le corno virus mais il ya eu
plus de 2000 interventions où l'on
suspectait des codes que v19 les
protocoles de sécurité d'urgences-santé
change presque toutes les semaines
depuis le début de la pandémie
aujourd'hui les ambulanciers ne met
presque plus les pieds à l'intérieur des
hôpitaux même l' architecture des lieux
et revu
c'est une ère qui va être aménagé aux
couvreurs faire la décontamination de
notre matériel nous a jamais est prévu
au départ que l'on fasse de la
décontamination et choses comme ça à
l'extérieur de quelques jours les
ambulanciers d'urgences santé ont créé
manqué de matériel de protection
l'utilisation des masques à cartouche
rechargeables a permis d'éviter une
pénurie de masques n95 la réalité notre
travail de paralyser ses les produits
c'est certain que c'est difficile
d'imaginer tout et scénarios possibles
mais à la question est cependant les
outils ou et on les a est-ce que c'est
facile nombre d'internats mai
pas plus pas moins que les autres qui
sont confinées à la maison on est une
tête dans le même bateau
la mesure que la coved 19 progresse la
charge de travail des ambulanciers
augmente elle aussi que je ressens ce
que je perçois c'est une fatigue aussi
très psychologique dans le sens où il
faut tout le temps qu'il faut'' tout
temps faire attention
d'accord du temps est vigilant donc ça
c'est une fatigue qui est différente de
la fatigue est habituel des
interventions classiques
ce ne sont pas seulement les
travailleurs de première ligne qui
vivent les contrecoups de cette crise
liée à leurs familles aussi qui sont
parfois séparés je voulais pas que mes
enfants deviennent des des vecteurs de
contamination pour leur mère
enfin que which you so très très très
très très dessus sur gvt wabho mais par
tex téléphone c'est la fête à monfils il
ya une dizaine d'années
le poitiers
ça sort
si simon couture radio canada montréal